Harley Quinn's popularity is a fairly
recent phenomenon so you might not
remember the finer details of her
backstory but with birds of prey hitting
cinemas and the new Suicide Squad on the
horizon now is a good time as any to
bone up on Harley's dark and checkered
past Harley Quinn is a member of a short
list of comic book characters who
weren't adapted from page to screen but
actually went about it the other way
around the carrots have first appeared
in Joker's favor a 1992 episode of
batman the animated series throughout
the show she made regular appearances as
a henchwoman obsessed with the Joker and
the Clown Prince of Crime clearly
doesn't reciprocate her feelings an
animated series writer Paul Dini
conceived of Harley Quinn while watching
his old college friend
Arleen Sorkin on Days of Our Lives saw
Kim dressed with a joker in a dream
sequence for the soap and the scene
inspired Dini to not only create Joker's
twisted girlfriend but to hire Sorkin to
voice' Sorkin went on to play Quinn on
numerous projects over the following
decades most recently for the online
ball playing game a DC Universe Online
speaking about a character to Starlog
magazine
Sorkin said she wants to be a good girl
but it's so much more to her to be a bad
one it would have taken seven years from
a TV debut for Harley Quinn to
officially become parts of the DC Comics
universe Quinn had previously appeared
in comics most memorably in the 1994 64
paid special the Batman adventures mad
love which established her origin as
Joker's former doctor at Arkham Asylum
but those comics were connected to the
world of the animated series and they
weren't part of the larger DC Comics
narrative Harley's first canonical
appearance in DC Comics came in 1999 s
Batman Harley Quinn issue 1 which made
up parts of the no man's land events in
which Gotham City is abandoned by the US
government after being destroyed by a
massive earthquake like a counterpart in
mad love this Harley was also Joker's
doctor and again she fell for him in a
big way
Part II helps Joker escaped Arkham
Asylum gets caught and is immediately
committed herself when the events of no
man's land enabled audio silence inmates
to escape
Quinn fine suggests a getup in an
abandoned costume store and seeks
I lost love of course Holley is as loyal
as always taking on penguin and his
goons for Joker and later going
one-on-one with Batman so Joker can make
his escape
obviously Joker's reward is to trick her
into going inside a rocket which he then
crashes remotely Holley survives and his
poison ivy who finds her and nurses her
back to health
kicking off a storied relationship for
the comics version of Harley the first
ongoing Harley Quinn comic premiered in
late 2000 in the first issue Harley is
still under Joker's spell in spite of
the abuse she's endured by his hand but
eventually with the help of poison ivy
Harley manages to see enough of the real
Joker to rebel against him and his
henchmen their renewed relationship ends
with Holley hurling the Clown Prince of
Crime into a neon sign the series ended
with 2004 Harley Quinn issue 38 a story
that left its hero with a bleak yet
predictable fate the final issue ends if
Harley deciding she belongs back home
and the penultimate page shows Harley in
the pouring rain pounding on the doors
of Arkham Asylum in the last pages final
panel as Quinn is led to a Cell her face
breaks into a smile
in 2009 Harley Quinn made some friends
that yes for the debut of Gotham City
sirens issue one in which Harley joins
forces with fellow female anti-heroes
Catwoman and poison ivy
it all starts after ivy saves Catwoman
from a super villain wannabe named bone
breaker after which she invites Selina
Kyle to a new home the apartment of the
Riddler who IV has rendered catatonic
with a mind-control powers and then
Harley shows up shortly afterward
announcing she's moving in it's clear
that even after years of abuse and
multiple attempts to kill each other
Halle is still obsessed with a Joker
shortly after arriving at Ivy's new pad
Harley and sis she's over mr. J then
seconds later excitedly asked if he's
called by the end of the issue the three
women have agreed to join forces and
leave Riddler's apartment for an
abandoned animal shelter Gotham City
sirens would only last 26 issues but if
nothing else it marked an important step
in the evolution of Harley Quinn
after all this series saw Harley's first
comic team up with other women in lead
roles a pattern that would be repeated
throughout the characters history in
August 2009 both DC fans and gamers
alike were treated to one of the
franchise's best ever video game
Batman Arkham Asylum in this hit game
the player takes on the role of Batman
who after delivering Joker to the
titular asylum is forced to suffer
breakout conceived by the Clown Prince
of Crime himself naturally Harley is all
too happy to get involved Holi appears a
fair bit throughout the game though
she's one of the only BAP villains that
the player never confronts physically
after sending squads of thugs after the
hero Harley is easily overpowered by
Batman in a cutscene was perhaps most
significant about Harley's spot in the
game however is that it's her first
major appearance in media without a
classic Jester suit instead she was a
nurse outfit sporting the twin ponytails
that would later become a Harley Quinn
staple believe it or not Harley Quinn
didn't appear at all in the first three
volumes of Suicide Squad but in the year
since she's since become such an
inseparable part of task force eggs that
is difficult to imagine there was a time
when the team of villains could function
without her Harley's 2011 debut in
Suicide Squad came as part of DC's line
wide reboot that new 52 during which
Harley's jester Luke was abandoned for
colourful ponytails and a much skimpier
outfit Adam glass wrote most of the
first 19 issues of the new volume
teaming party up with Task Force X
mainstays like Deadshot and Captain
Boomerang as well as newer additions
like king shark and Diablo there have
been two subsequent volumes of Suicide
Squad since the new 52 series ended with
its 30th issue as well as a short-lived
a new Suicide Squad with Harley center
stage every turn girl loves the
spotlight three years after the debut of
the new 52 Harley once again starred in
her own solo series this time Harley's
story was co-written by a team that has
since become a fan favorite Amanda
Connor and Jimmy Party these two writers
arguably became so popular because they
knew just why people love Harley because
she's fun the series opens of Harley
being willed an entire apartment
building on Coney Island
from an old patient there she's joined
by hilarious supporting characters such
as the x-bike cyborg man and the dead
beaver Burnie
who is in constant contact of Harley
despite you know being dead for a long
time there was rampant speculation that
Harley Quinn and fellow Gotham City
antihero poison ivy were more than just
friends they'd been trading innuendo and
and comics cartoons and even videogames
for years but it was a long time before
there was any kind of official word on
the matter
however Wright says Jimmy Palmer Yahtzee
and Amanda Connor confirmed Harley and
IVs relationship status in 2015 and in
2017 harley quinn issue 25 fans finally
got to see these two characters share a
kiss
sadly Ivy's unexpected death in a 2018
miniseries heroes in crisis is part of
what drives Harley over the edge and
again puts her on a collision course
with a group of heroes including Batman
and Booster Gold thankfully this isn't
the end of ivy by the end of the series
has discovered the Ivy prepared for her
death by creating a plant-based clone of
herself since then Harvey and the new
ivy have teamed up for the 2019 Harley
Quinn and poison ivy miniseries in 2016
Harley Quinn finally made her way to the
big screen sporting a baseball bats and
shorts combo and David a is Suicide
Squad rising star Margot Robbie was cast
in a role of the mentally unhinged Quinn
after impressing critics and audience
set with her performance at Martin
Scorsese's the wolf of Wall Street
a mr. and samba cast including superstar
Will Smith Viola Davis and Jared Leto
Robbie's version of Harley was a genuine
standouts I'm known to be quite vexing
I'm just poor warning you ladies shut up
of course it's no secret that Suicide
Squad wasn't exactly a favorite of the
critics but even the critics who
couldn't stand the movie as a whole
pointed to Robbie's performance as a
merciful exception the chicago tribune's
michael phillips for example wrote
Robbie is radioactively watchable
swinging her baseball bats at this way
and that selling this skeezy male
fantasy nut job with wide-eyed
enthusiasm in early 2018
DC Comics announced the launch of his
black label imprint DC black label
promised to give premiere talent the
opportunity to tell stand alone but your
reader stories outside of the current DC
Universe continuity this freedom allows
creators to tell exactly the stories
they want to tell without worrying about
impacting the broader DC Comics universe
and that she might have guessed Harley
Quinn has already proven to be the star
of two of the imprints miniseries
Pauline and Joker Harley criminal sanity
Joker Harley criminal sanity by writer
kami Garcia
reframes Harley's origins completely in
becoming a comic-book life as Joker's
doctor in Arkham Asylum the Harley of
criminal sanity is a criminal profiler
assisting the Gotham police department
in tracking down a killer meanwhile
sapin Shah jees Harleen offers a more
familiar dr. Harleen Quinzel of Arkham
Asylum but refuses to take a
relationship with the Joker for granted
instead the shays takes readers on a
slow burn intriguing trip in order to
show exactly how the flawed dr. Quinzel
could become so tragically obsessed with
the Joker in February 20 2010 swil
finally get the chance to see margot
robbie reprise her role of harley and
birds of prey and a fantabulous
emancipation of one harley quinn the
film takes place after a bad breakup
between Harley and the Joker and like
the DC Universe animated series Harley
Quinn the anti heroine is now on a quest
to make her own way in the world along
the way she's joined by a number of
mainstays from DC's mythos such as
jurnee smollett bells black canary mary
elizabeth winstead Huntress rosie perez
is former Gotham cop Renee Montoya and
allergy Bosco's Cassandra Cain
Joker doesn't appear in the film in
person though instead Holly and her new
allies face Ewan McGregor's maniacal
crime lord black mask the birds of prey
up had a number of series over the years
and they even had their own short-lived
television series in the early odds but
Hartley's addition to the movie team and
her prominence in the lineup is one of
the biggest supporters from the birds of
prey comics on the page she really has
nothing to do with the crew at all now
though just like with Suicide Squad her
name is pretty much inseparable from the
brand Harley Quinn is taking over the
world check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite anti heroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you
[Music]